foreign
the World Cup hasn't kicked off in Qatar
but the party is already on the way
[Music]
we have boundary music and we have
thousands
plenty of hype for the dark Festival to
celebrate South Asian culture these
people are hyped we spoke to one of the
organizers earlier to tell us what it's
all about the festival is celebrating
the manasa Europe culture which is the
Middle East North Africa and South Asia
tonight we are celebrating South Asia
you have amazing roaming shows from
drummers acrobats to dancers
Qatar has worked hard to make sure that
we can offer something for everyone
[Music]
well just around the corner from Lucille
Boulevard is of course Lucedale Stadium
it's where the World Cup final is going
to be held that is a Bollywood concert
there tonight and thousands of people
are heading there it's a good chance to
test out the facilities ahead of the
World Cup now of course this is a South
Asian festival all together here in
Lucille and of course there are no South
Asian teams at the World Cup that
doesn't mean there's no shortage of
passion from their fans
[Music]
[Music]
Brazil
well back here on Lucille Boulevard the
fun continues one thing is for sure with
the World Cup just a couple of weeks
away excitement builds day by day in
Qatar
[Music]